الا الله
ورسول
نبينا
اجمع
[Silence]
العيد
‏is
a ma
and this kind of
سنه مؤكده
লংخ
الاسلام رحمه
مذاهب
صلاه العيد
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ام عطيه
رضي الله عنها قالت امرنا ان نخرج العواتق
وذوات الخدور يعني الى الصلاه
شي منشن رضي الله عنها
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم صلاه العيد
evenyle
صلاه
صلاه صلاه العيد
اسلام
[Silence]
قالت
احدى النساء للنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يا
رسول الله على احدانا باس اذا لم يكن لها
جلباب الا تخرج يعني الى صلاه العيد فقال
لتلبسها صاحبتها من جلبابها
فليشهدن الخير ودعوه المؤمنين
ان بخاري مسلم
ذ
فيميل كبينز رضي الله عنها
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلاه العيد
العيد
صلى الله عليه وسلم
nothing
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه وسلم لتلبسها صاحبتها من
جلبابها
‏The woman
is to dress her sister of herb. ‏to get
in someone who has an additional
who has an additional
something additional to
where and to give it to her sister to
wear.
‏I don't know. I mean, I'm talking about
stuff for women and all the women are
talking and me.
Oh, well, you know, I hope you feel
better. Do you need any help with
something?
Oh, we got a full of
الحمد لله.
‏And so the emphasis on
so great even
said someone else put on
because
صلى الله عليه وسلم
فليشهدنا الخير ودعوه المؤمنين
‏are
of
so not
beingl
[Silence]
‏engصلاه
الفجر
in time
after
speength
15 minutes
between the horizon and
so this is happen now some
العيد
عيد الفطر
عيد الاضحى
صلاه عيد الفطر
عيد
عيد الاضحى
‏not
anything until you eat from
time
عيد صلاه
زكاه الفطر
صدقه
الاضحيه الاضحيه
عيد صلاه
ذبيحه لحم
اضحيه
صلاه العيد
صلاه عيد الفطر
صلاه
عيد الاضحى
commطر
[Silence]
صلاه العيد
صلاه العيد made
of
community
‏So for instance here in this community
we have isue with logistics let say weve
only got one road that will bring you in
there's an issue of paring there's an
issue of logistics right then we would
time
to accommodate those logistics and that
is why the prophet
was made the
صلاه العيد
all the upeson
of the sky before
time to be able
صلاه العيد
اذان اقامه صلاه العيد صلاه العيد
صلاه
ركعه
صلاه العيد ركعه
تكبي
ركعهم الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
تكبير
الله
[Silence]
مفج
علي
‏peopleen
people have time understand what you be
able to person next to you and that's
the point
you know the people come to constantly
the people come and listen to thees on a
daily bas you are chosen group of people
to take on this knowledge take on this
information and teach it to others
صلاه العيد
صلاه
ركعه
تكبي
differبي
الله اكبر
رضي الله عنهم
سبحان الله الحمد لله لا اله الا الله
الله اكبر ولا قوه الا بالله
ذكر mindكرات
تكبي
تكبيا
صلاه
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
[Silence]
12 12
ولبر
على ما هداكم
ولعكم تشكرون الله سبحانه وتعالى
عده
تكبير الله
make
الله سبحانه وتعالى
تكب
‏If
did it would be incorrect
that
propetised
for each
narrated that عمر and rais their hands
but they are kind of weak chains of
narration ‏So it is best person
but if did it would not be
now
often confused in
between the two عيد الاضحى
عيد الفطر
التكبير المقيد
التكبير المقيد ولز التكبير المقيد يسر
[Silence]
صلاه العيد
makeلاصلاه
while
[Silence]
صلاه العيد
soج
‏could
moreate
each of us make
now
of confusedبير
المقب
المقيد
make تكبير
صلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا
اله الا الله
تكبير specially
عيد الاضحى
عيد الفطر
التكبير المطلق
تكبير
[Silence]
سنه
عيد الفطر
فجر
صلاه
تكبير عيد الفطر
عيد الاضحى
ان
فجر
مغرب
عرفه
محرم
ذحج
تكبير مقيد
تكبير
صلاه
صلوات
صلاه المغرب after صلاه المغرب
عرفه
before
تكبير
صلاه المغرب
عشاء فجر
عصر
مغرب
عرفه عرفه
الاضحى
التشري
عصر
الحجه
عيد رمضان
فجر
‏fines
after
الاضحى
عيد رمضان
تكبير
صلاه
some
of
that
تكبير مقيد
تكبير
تكبيرجر
صلاه العيد now
we
make
do we
جمعه
عيد خطبه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
عيد
جمعه
صلاه العيد
صلاه الجمعه
[Silence]
جمعه
peopleخ
صلى الله عليه وسلم
جمعه
صل الله عليه
‏want
and two
acts of fall at the apprate time with
each other
الله سبحانه وتالى allows us to do one
and not have to do the
صلاه العيد
جمعه
صلاه الجمعهم
خطبه
[Silence]
‏people
م صلاه العيد سنن ابي داوود
انا نحن سنخطب
فمن اراد ان يستمع
فليستمع ومن اراد ان ينصرف فليفعل او كما
قال صلى الله عليه وسلم
this important point made صلاه العيد
the companion
[Silence]
‏usithat
‏are not
and chat
and those are listening to the
categorically
‏So listening
is not
meaning you will not be burned inell
failing to do so however it is highly
encouraged the prop
that allowance why because he required
everyone come to eat the slaves the wom
‏are things need to back right
there need to
fires need to made things need to be
done so he gave that allowance that look
you make the you can and go do what you
have
you are listen خطبه that's the purpose
of the allowance so I have said all
to pray ew
[Silence]
‏No, this is
this is an important point and that is
that is supposed to unite. ‏not supposed
to divide
is one time with the
point of
not to make more than once more than one
day and whoever wants to choose can
choose we have more than one prayer
because of paring and logistics and all
that stuff a lot of the first prayer
here is from the
‏here
our
time for this comm
time of the صلاه therefore you would
come at that and you would make that
you would make both of them because
that's kind that go against the nature
[Silence]
‏all
for
in one place at one time at one day with
one that's the
العيد
صلاه العيد
صلى الله عليه وسلم
جمعه
‏and all have one
when we are fractured and we have 20
different and you can choose right if
you don't this over here you can go
over here and if you don't this you
can go over here this is what weakens
the musl to next so we will end with
thatك
غيرك وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
ان شاء الله السلام
السلام